Stephen twitch boss's mom Connie shares
her heartbreaking wish following his
sudden death on Tuesday night the late
dancer's mom shared this image to her
insta story a screenshot of a FaceTime
with her son she wrote alongside it
quote Oh if only I could Face Time To
Heaven followed by a blue heart and a
broken heart emoji and never take for
granted the moments that I can make my
mom proud last week fans were devastated
to learn twitch was found dead at a
motel in Encino California less than a
mile from his home which he shared with
his wife Allison Hulker and their two
kids six-year-old son Maddox and
three-year-old daughter ziya twitch was
also dad to hulker's 14 year old
daughter Wesley from a previous
relationship we love the Full House and
also just like family man like honestly
they're my favorite they're my favorite
people twitch died of a self-inflicted
gunshot wound to the head and one day
after news broke of his death Connie
spoke out on Instagram thanking her
family and friends for for all the love
prayers and encouragement quote I can't
use words right now please know I will
reach out when I can please continue to
keep us in prayer and she ended her post
with a message to her son Steve and
Laurel your mother loves you to Eternity
and Beyond I'm still in a lot of shock
um my daughter is really close with
Wesley his daughter and our kids went to
school together and he and I went to
college together and um
yeah it's a lot so twitch's death rocked
Hollywood many of his friends opening up
to E.T he's such a talent and such an
amazing warm wonderful heart and yeah he
will be he will be greatly missed we've
always crossed Paths of twitch and he is
was the nicest guy ever I've been an
advocate for mental health for a long
time I've had my own Journey with it I
think many of us have but to know that
someone that you would never ever expect
you would never have imagined twitch's
wife Allison confirms the news of his
death in an emotional statement to ET
reflecting on her husband's Life and
Legacy I have the sweetest husband in
the entire world quote we love you we
miss you and I will always Save the Last
Dance For You which is sometimes fun
like to have a partner in life that I
can also dance with you know it just
makes every single day so fun according
to deadline twitch and Allison had a big
lineup of projects slated for the new
year they were in the process of
developing their own show called living
the dream which would help first-time
buyers find a home they were also
working on a show at HGTV where they
would oversee construction of a
full-sized Malibu Barbie Dream House
filming was scheduled to begin in
January while it's unclear if the show
will move forward HGTV said in a
statement they're considering different
scenarios but for now their primary
focus remains on way wishing their best
to Allison and the entire Boss family
during this difficult time
[Music]